[Music]  oh oh  I'm trying to get mommy fun  oh wow okay talk about adorable Rihanna  gives fans the first look at her seven  month old baby boy with ASAP Rocky in  her debut video on Tick Tock and just  like Mommy he doesn't appear to be  camera shy as she's seen here trying to  get a hold of the phone  [Music]  Rihanna and ASAP welcome their first  child together back in May and while  Riri has yet to disclose his name she  sure did tell our friends at E.T about  her favorite part of being a mom sharing  the mornings like seeing his morning  face seeing a baby with like bags waking  up and they're just like startled  they're trying to figure out where  they're at it's the cutest it's my  favorite part of the day